[Musique]
attendez je
suis politique ce matin ça a commencé ça
a commencé merci
beaucoup
merci d'être notre invité secrétaire
nationale d'Europe Écologie never on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour Stéphane Vernet
bonjour bonjour Stéphane de Ouest-France
merci également d'être avec nous on va
parler de la feuille de route de la
transition écologique on imagine que
vous l'attendiez avec impatience vous
l'avez eu hier soir Emmanuel Macron l'a
dévoilé on va revenir dans les détails
mais d'abord est-ce qu'il vous a
convaincu le chef de l'État hier soir je
vais vous décevoir parce que tout le
monde me pose cette question dans c'est
bon vous êtes contents maintenant les
écolos et c'est vrai que j'aurais adoré
pouvoir venir ce matin me réjouir en me
disant c'est bon tout est tout est sous
la bonne voie et tout est sous contrôle
malheureusement ça n'est pas le cas j'ai
été la première à dire que l'exercice de
planification était extrêmement
intéressante parce que le constat qui
est posé par ce document et assez lucide
inédit c'est un bon exercice mais quand
on voit tous les constats qui sont posés
par exemple on nous dit il y a 20 à 30
000 hectares qui sont artificialisés par
an en France ces deux à trois fois la
surface de Paris tous les ans qui sont
artificialisés en France quand on nous
dit à 60 % des oiseaux des champs
d'Europe qui ont disparu en 40 ans quand
on y a 85 communes qui avaient plus
d'eau au robinet cet été on attend un
plan d'ampleur et quand on entend les
annonces d'Emmanuel Macron dimanche soir
et puis lundi forcément on est déçu je
vous donne deux exemples le premier
c'est des centrales à charbon en 2017
Emmanuel Macron candidat dit
en 2022 il n'y aura plus de centrales à
charbon dans ce pays bon là on est en
2023 donc on regarde le bilan bon bah
elles sont encore là et ils nous dis il
prend la même phrase c'est l'économie
circulaire vous savez le recyclage il
prend la même phrase il change les dates
dit nous sommes en 2023 en 2027 il n'y
aura plus de centrales à charbon mais
comment on le croit quand c'est
exactement la même phrase dit qu'elles
seront converties en biomasse c'est pas
ici mais il avait dit la même chose en
2017 en disant je m'y engage en 2022 il
y aura plus de centrales à charbon donc
ils sont encore là le glyphosate c'est
encore plus saisissant parce que là il
m'aime il régresse sur l'objectif en
2017 là il est président de la
République et il fait vous savez c'était
au moment les sites de Greta thumberg de
la scène internationale il avait mis le
hashtag make en planète et il dit le
glyphosate je m'y engage dans 3 ans la
France on sera sorti et donc là tous les
gens ils se disent mais alors les écolos
vous êtes calmé vous savez plus à rien
l'écologie c'est Macron etc il avait dit
on sera sorti donc en 2020 du glyphosate
on est en 2023 on en est pas sorti du
tout et là dans le plan c'est écrit non
mais mesure d'ampleur on va baisser la
dépendance au glyphosate de 30%.
franchement parce qu'il y a pas de
solution pour les agriculteurs et il a
dit en 2017
et il les a pas en 2023 bon bah c'est un
peu compliqué quand on est président de
la République et la question n'est pas
de faire de l'écologie pour ou contre
les agriculteurs vous pensez que moi je
me lève le matin en disant bon bah
aujourd'hui faire de l'écologie contre
les agriculteurs la question c'est de
leur dire aussi la vérité et si on veut
aider l'agriculture moi je pose des
mesures qui sont très écologiques sur la
table par exemple la fin le suspension
des projets de ferme usine parce que les
frères usines ce ne sont pas des fermes
ce sont des usines quand vous offrez une
ferme à vos enfants à vos neveux et
nièces à Noël vous offrez pas un truc de
26 étages avec des pores à tous les
étages pas de fenêtre et des animaux qui
peuvent pas bouger vous offrez une
petite ferme La Prairie etc c'est ça la
vision d'élevage qu'on a en France et
aujourd'hui 60% de la viande dans notre
pays et produite par 3% des exploitants
dans des fermes qui sont un désastre
pour l'écologie un désastre pour le
bien-être animal et un désastre il faut
le dire pour le bien-être donc en
résumer
sa soirée à dire écologie au service de
l'économie économie économie économie
mais l'écologie française oui mais
l'écologie à la fin c'est pas pour
l'économie c'est pour les gens c'est
pour le vivant et les gens ne sont pas
dans son plan moi je voulais qu'il
explique aux Français ce qui allait
changer dans leur vie j'ai pas compris
ça alors ça ça viendra peut-être après
mais vous dites que l'exercice de
planification extrêmement intéressante
le constat est lucide mais par contre
sur les méthodes ou les propositions ce
que vous attendiez à quelque chose à une
rupture et c'est ça qui vous manque
aujourd'hui dans ce dans cette démarche
parce que planification c'est bien les
réunions la communication mais il faut
de l'action et comment vous faites une
planification écolo sans ne supprimer
aucun grand projet autoroutier sans le
supprimer aucun projet de méga bassine
sans le supprimer aucun projet de ferme
usine ça marche pas et surtout ce qu'il
faut dire aux gens puisqu'on est là pour
leur dire la vérité c'est que tous ces
projets ça coûtait énormément d'argent
public énormément d'argent public pour
des projets anachroniques obsolètes
dégradants pour l'humain pour le vivant
et donc si on économie cet argent public
si dans notre côté il n'en a pas du tout
parlé on met en place un ISF climatique
un impôt sur les grandes fortunes ça on
est pour depuis bien longtemps chez les
écolos mais cibler sur le climat
c'est-à-dire qu'on taxe plus celles et
ceux qui vivent de projets climaticides
et cet argent est réattribué à des
politiques écologiques alors on dégage
beaucoup de marches financières et avec
ces marches financières on peut faire un
truc très simple plus de bonheur pour
les gens faire en sorte qu'ils vivent
mieux qu'ils mangent mieux qu'ils se
déplace mieux qu'ils accès à des
transports en commun de qualité qui
respire un meilleur une tondeuse comme
projet avec ce qui a été proposé ces
deux jours l'objectif de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de 55% des
synonymes 2030 sera tenue par la France
bah là aussi je suis inquiète parce que
ils disent c'est bon on a baissé les 5
dernières années de 2% par an les
émissions de CO2 comme si c'était la
pensée magique grâce à lui donc on
continue c'est bon la réalité c'est que
non mais vous étiez là les trois
dernières années comme moi il y a eu le
covid toute l'activité économique a été
ralentie on va pas refaire un covid tous
les ans pour tenir nos objectifs CO2 il
y a eu la crise énergétique et donc des
Françaises et des Français qui se sont
privés d'accès à l'énergie qui ont
réduit
leur température dans domicile etc des
entreprises qui ont été aussi
extrêmement contraintes et puis il y a
eu aussi un hiver particulièrement doux
bon ça c'est plus amené à se reproduire
quand même mais vous voyez bien que on
peut pas se dire comme il y a eu ces
événements ça c'est bon tout se passe
bien et on sera pas la tenue pour vous
vous êtes ta pessimiste sur la tenue de
cet objectif pas quelqu'un de pessimiste
donc moi j'ai envie d'y croire mais je
me rends bien compte que des politiques
écologistes qui ne sont pas mis en
oeuvre par des écolos ça ne peut pas
marcher et voyez dans ce plan par
exemple puisque j'ai dit que le constat
était lucide on nous dit 12 % des
émissions de CO2 du pays 12 % de toutes
les émissions de la France sont liées à
la viande à l'élevage ou à la
consommation de viande bah du coup on se
dit dans le plan on va retrouver des
mesures super et ben il n'y a sur ce
sujet tenez-vous bien rien et donc c'est
un peu déstabilisant et déconcertants et
on voit bien que c'est des mesures qui
sont courageuses qui sont nécessaires et
en fait on peut pas transformer le
climat et un pays sur le plan écologique
sans rien faire sur l'agriculture et
donc on a un problème dans ce pays aussi
de du poids des politiques écolos par
rapport à d'autres politiques et sur le
plan agricole ces manifeste moi de toute
façon je vois mal Marc fenault vu au
service de qui il est pas des éleveurs
des agriculteurs et des petits paysans
mais de d'un syndicat majoritaire qui
est la FNSEA qui est quasiment
progression aujourd'hui du ministère de
l'agriculture mais parce que l'écologie
ça demande d'aller contrôler lobbies ça
demande de ne pas faire une politique
qui soit forte avec les faibles et
faibles avec l'effort et ce gouvernement
c'est un peu sa spécialité de faire ça
et donc on voit à la fin que les aides
agricoles par exemple vont continuer à
au plus gros à l'agriculture intensive
qui destructeur du vivant de
l'environnement et aussi des petits
paysans et que tant qu'on veut pas
changer ça biologique aussi on verra
parce que c'est pas ce qui se passe
depuis 6 ans le bio est en crise vous le
savez les aides ont été ré-attribués il
y a plus d'aide il y a une aide quand
vous vous convertissez au bio il y a
plus d'aide au maintien du bio alors que
les agriculteurs bio qui font l'effort
de faire ça ils rendent un service
écologique toute l'année et on devrait
les rétribuer de ça c'est plus le cas on
va parler des carburants Stéphane du
chèque d'Emmanuel Macron mais oui le
chèque de 100 euros pour aider les
Français les travailleurs les plus
modestes qui ont besoin de rouler les
gros rouleurs est-ce que c'est une
mesure que vous soutenez
je fais une petite ainsi sur le
carburant parce que le carburant c'est
la voiture et j'ai entendu dimanche soir
évidemment j'ai entendu dimanche soir
que Emmanuel Macron disait j'aime la
bagnole bon il y a qu'un jour il avait
dit qu'il aimait l'avion donc il aime
aussi les pesticides les jets privés les
méga bassines et le pétrole puisqu'il a
quand même remis la Légion d'Honneur la
Légion d'honneur qu'on devrait plutôt
remettre aux infirmières aux pompiers et
aux profs lui il a remise à pouillané le
PDG de Total énergie bon on a compris
mais c'est bien
on en a besoin en fait de la voiture
dans plein d'endroits en France dont là
où j'habite mais je vais pas à la télé
dire j'aime la bagnole il avait déjà dit
quand il était candidat qu'il aimait les
gros moteurs et accélérer à fond pour
tester les moteurs ok on a compris c'est
super on est content mais là nous on est
là pour faire de l'écologie sur le
carburant il a annoncé il y a une
semaine qu'ils allaient faire vous savez
autoriser les ventes à pertes en station
les écologistes ont été les premiers à
dire ça ne marchera pas c'est au service
de la grande distribution des grands
hypermarchés ça va faire couler les
petites stations il faut des chèques
ciblés bon bah on avait une semaine
un gouvernement d'annoncer des trucs et
dire une semaine après alors on a écouté
ouais en fait c'est vrai c'était pas
possible donc vous êtes contente du
chèque j'espère qu'il va pas changer
d'avis sur les trucs écolo qu'il a
annonçait la semaine prochaine du coup
parce que ça crée un peu d'un constance
dans ce pays et sur le chèque je ne
pense pas que 100 €, ça suffise pour
plein de français 100 euros par an
calculer ce que ça fait en nombre de
plans ça fait quand même pas en même
temps est-ce que c'est judicieux de
financer des énergies fossiles parce que
c'est ça avec de l'argent public vous
savez on est dans un urgence mais en
même temps ça va ça va l'encontre de ce
que vous prenez évidemment il en tant
que écologie je serai la première à vous
le dire on est dans un pays qui depuis
des décennies a organisé la dépendance
au pétrole et donc quand tout d'un coup
vous dites sevrage on arrête bah les
gens ne peuvent pas faire autrement il y
a des endroits où ils peuvent il y a des
salaires qui peuvent se permettre de
payer l'essence au prix où elle est
actuellement et d'autres non et donc ce
que doit faire la politique publique
c'est pas dire l'essence va être moins
cher pour tout le monde continuer il y a
pas de problème parce que la politique
mondiale l'épuisement des ressources en
pétrole qui est mécaniques et
géologiques fait que de toute manière de
toute manière les prix vont augmenter
mais quand vous habitez dans des
territoires comme le mien où on vous
parle d'un RER chez pas quoi depuis 10
ans et qu'on vous dit non mais là on a
un nouveau plan et tout Macron a fait un
contrat de plan et ta région peut-être
qu'en 2040 vous aurez un RER pour aller
à Lille bon bah ok il reste 100 millions
il reste quelques années ok pour 2040
parce que ça fait des ça fait des années
que les petites lignes de TER sont pas
entretenues parce que c'est le tout TGV
et donc plein de Françaises et de
français comme moi se retrouvent parfois
obligé de prendre la voiture parce que
les alternatives n'existent pas et donc
c'est cher qu'il faut les cibler sur
deux populations celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas d'alternative pour aller
travailler et celles et ceux qui en ont
le moins les moyens et donc je préfère
qu'on donne
pas à tout le monde mais plus à celles
et ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin c'est
ça la justice environnementale c'est ça
la justice sociale et souvent les deux
sont indissociablement liés tout à
l'heure qui aura besoin d'énormément
d'argent public pour financer pour
financer tout ça c'est la semaine du des
on commence à étudier les textes
budgétaires au Parlement les objectifs
fixés
l'État va consacrer 40 milliards d'euros
pardon le l'an prochain aux questions de
transition écologique est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour vous alors les milliards
moi j'entends tout le temps partout
j'aimerais bien voir où sont à la fin
vous savez c'est comme Aurore berger qui
la semaine dernière dit 20 milliards
pour le plan pauvreté ok
c'est pas pourquoi faire on sait pas si
c'est pour des nouveaux dispositifs si
elle compte des choses qui existaient
déjà parce que ce gouvernement a quand
même le don et là c'est du recyclage on
sait très bien pour annoncer la même
chose toutes les semaines les 7
milliards de plus que l'année dernière
on a besoin de savoir où ils sont si
c'est des crédits de paiement des
autorisations d'engagement c'est de
l'argent qui sera vraiment dépensé cette
année et au service de qui parce que moi
parfois je vois des défenses dites
environnementales si c'est pour faire
des EPR par exemple ah bah ça va coûter
même plus que 7 milliards mais je suis
pas sûr que ça change vraiment de
quotidien des Français et que ce soit ça
sur lequel on a envie que ça aille en
priorité donc vous voyez c'est le sujet
est pas le nombre de milliards
évidemment que ça compte mais c'est
pourquoi faire est-ce que demain les
écologistes c'est une loi en fait de
programmation de finances sur les
questions de transition écologique qu'on
puisse très régulièrement aller voir par
rapport aux objectifs sur ce sujet
précis ce qui est fait comment ça évolue
qu'il y a une vraie transparence on le
fait sur plein d'autres questions dans
ce pays on devrait le faire sur la
transition écologique sur le budget
Stéphane les écologistes voteront les
textes budgétaires cette année pas du
tout c'est qu'elle sera la position du
Parti bah franchement ça va être
compliqué parce que vous voyez bien moi
j'ai rencontré avec Cyrielle châtelain
qui est président de notre groupe
Elizabeth borne la semaine dernière
on lui parle par exemple des vous savez
des niches dans le projet de loi de
finance des endroits où en fait on fait
des avantages fiscaux pour des choses
qui sont anti-écolos totalement pour les
pour les l'avions par exemple pour les
Corrèzes des avions il y a plein de
sujets comme ça quand même chaque année
l'État finance des dispositifs fiscaux
avantageux pour les trucs qui sont
climaticides qui tuent le vivant et donc
nous on met sur la table la disparition
de ces niches et ça ne sent pas
d'actualité et donc tant que sur des
principes de base comme ça on verra pas
les choses avancées c'est extrêmement
difficile de faire confiance sur le plan
environnemental
Macron dimanche soir a pointé les mères
qui augmentent la taxe foncière oui
j'étais pas contente il y a des mères
écologistes parmi ces mères que vous
dites-vous Emmanuel Macron ben c'est
vraiment été extrêmement choquée par sa
charge contre les mers parce qu'en plus
on sentait bien vous savez la stratégie
de d'évitement c'est-à-dire qu'on lui
pose une question sur l'impôt
et bon bah il s'est pas trop répondre
donc il dit non mais la taxe foncière
augmente mais moi je vais le dire c'est
pas de la faute de Léna allez voir vos
mères c'est OK augmente la taxe foncière
c'est extrêmement choquant pour pour
trois points le premier c'est qui il
ment il dit c'est pas du tout l'État
c'est que les mères mais vous voyez bien
que le les bases sur lesquelles sont
assis cette imposition cette taxe
foncière augmenter de 7 % dans un projet
de loi de finance ça c'est l'état ça
c'est l'état donc immense deuxièmement
ce qu'il oublie de dire là c'est un
mensonge par omission c'est que les
dotations la dotation globale de l'État
qui est donnée aux collectivités a
baissé de 50% en 10 ans bon c'était pas
que lui là ça va faire deux années de
suite qu'elle augmente c'était pas que
lui mais il se trouve qu'il était quand
même secrétaire général adjoint de
l'Elysée puis le ministre de l'Économie
et donc évidemment que les communes
quand elles ont plus la dotation globale
que l'État elles doivent pour certaines
étrangler financièrement et avec de plus
en plus de demandes de leurs concitoyens
augmenter la augmente et l'augmenter
dans le budget de l'année dernière elle
s'est augmenté dans le budget de ça très
récemment mais les décisions étaient
prises par les collectivités et puis
troisièmement il met en première ligne
de la colère français les mères dont on
sait premièrement que c'est lui qui
avait dit ils sont apportés de BAF et
deuxièmement que il y a de plus en plus
de d'agressions d'incivilités de menaces
contre les élus locaux sur lequel ils
ont été d'une impuissance et d'une
inaction qui est coupable d'une grande
lâcheté politique ils les ont laissé en
première ligne et donc plutôt que de
s'excuser en disant on va mieux de vous
aider il repousse devant au bord de la
falaise en disant allez-y on va regarder
si vous savez nager j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment très inéligant et quasiment
irresponsable on va parler des
sénatoriales le qui ont eu lieu dimanche
le groupe écologiste va progresser
est-ce que ce matin vous savez combien
vous aurez de sénateurs précisément dans
votre groupe écologiste alors notre
groupe se réunit pour la première fois
ce midi je suis extrêmement fière de ce
que nous avons fait parce que les gens
disent c'est normal les écolos ils ont
plus de merde donc ils vont avoir plus
de sénateurs mais les départements qui
étaient renoulés cette année à part
l'Indre-et-Loire ce n'est pas du tout
les départements où nous avons les
grandes villes écologistes parce que le
Sénat est renouvelé par moitié donc le
fait qu'on augmente le groupe de
de quelques sénateurs en fait c'est un
exploit dans cette séquence et regarder
dans les autres groupes du Sénat c'est
quand même le cas de très peu de groupes
d'augmenter autant et surtout nous
allons féminiser je peux pas vous dire
ce que le dépôt des groupes c'est le 3
octobre nous sommes encore en discussion
mais nous ferons nous espérons combien
je pense entre 15 et 17 entre 15 et 17
et sachant que nous étions 12 et donc
évidemment bon les nouveaux élus Europe
écologie des verts seront dans ce groupe
et puis nous avons des discussions avec
des compagnons de route dans certaines
dans certains départements avec qui nous
travaillons depuis longtemps et que nous
avons fait pendentifs en
Nouvelle-Calédonie par exemple vous
espérez qu'il va rejoindre votre groupe
bah je pense que ce serait souhaitable
parce qu'on a déjà dans notre groupe un
collègue Corse qui qui est comme le
collègue de noël-calédonie chez région
et peuple solidaire un parti avec lequel
nous travaillons depuis plus de 20 ans
au Parlement européen et on a toujours
travaillé très bien que les
régionalistes donc ce serait logique
après c'est à lui prendre sa décision je
pense qu'à l'heure qu'il est encore en
Nouvelle-Calédonie donc on va lui
laisser le temps d'arriver mais vous
voyez moi surtout ce dont je suis fier
c'est qu'on fait rentrer au Sénat
d'Olivier 29 ans qui est qui va être la
benjamine du Sénat et pouvoir
diversifier rajeunir féminiser le Sénat
moi qui ai travaillé quelques années il
y a un peu de temps maintenant ça me
fait plaisir parce que je vois bien que
ce groupe écologiste au Sénat il est
singulier il est singulier ils étaient
trois pour cent seulement des effectifs
du Sénat ils ont fait adopter 10 % des
amendements de la précédentement nature
donc oui ça rend fier et je me dis
qu'avec quelques membres de plus dans ce
groupe on va faire encore mieux il y a
un autre groupe qui a qui a qui a
enregistré des bons résultats ou des
résultats qui étaient pas qui était pas
évident au départ ce sont les
communistes est-ce que vous allez vous
chamailler pour pour grappiller un poste
à droite à gauche
vous me connaissez mal parce que
chamaille jamais avec les partenaires et
notamment dans notre région c'est Katia
pour sooli qui a été élu dans le
Pas-de-Calais avec qui je travaille
depuis très longtemps c'est la
présidente de la mission bassin minier
on se connaît très bien on travaille
depuis très longtemps ensemble donc je
ne me chamaille pas avec les copains
à droite et à l'extrême droite
pas ça va se jouer là c'est pas un
concours on va y venir à vos amis mais
d'abord un mot de votre région de votre
département puisque dans les hauts de
France il y a deux sénateurs du
rassemblement national qui vont faire
leur entrée sur les trois que va compter
la Haute Assemblée donc Christopher
Juret que vous connaissez bien puisqu'il
était lu comme vous d'énums est-ce que
c'est pas la preuve aussi de votre
impuissance a affaiblir le rassemblement
national ah bah c'est certain que moi je
vais vous dire je me suis engagée en
politique j'étais très jeune mon mère
socialiste était emprison parce que il
avait 18 chefs d'incubation qui allaient
de la corruption du favoritif avec toute
la collection de ce qui pouvait faire de
pas bien comme mère il a été démis de
ses fonctions de mer par le Conseil des
ministres c'était la première fois sur
la 5e République et donc quand vous avez
un bassin minier avec la fermeture des
mines de charbon puis ne rien du
stérilisation ratée puis les affaires
politiques au judiciaires vous vous
arrivez vous vous avez 25 ans vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez c'est
c'est inaudible la gauche a été
décrédibilisée pour beaucoup de temps
quand même dans ce département sur des
trucs qui sont arrivés quand j'étais au
lycée bon bah c'est comme ça et là
dans ces sénatorial notamment dans votre
région notamment sur votre territoire
mais évidemment d'ailleurs vous voyez
qu'on parle de Sébastien Chenu ou de
Christopher Zurich enfin c'est tout
l'arc de l'ancien bassin minier ça fait
250 km de long donc c'est quand même
même problème même conséquence et
Christopher Zurich voilà moi je le
connais bien on a à peu près le même âge
on est dans la même ville et les
premiers adjoint je suis dans
l'opposition je ne doute pas de son
combat politique de pourquoi il fait ça
quand on s'engage c'est souvent pour
pour des idées enfin c'est quand même un
peu d'abnégation mais je vois bien ce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire comme il
est jeune qu'il a le profil du gendre
idéal ils vont vouloir en faire le une
des nouvelles un des nouveaux visages du
FN New Age des diabolisé moi je sais par
qui il a été formé quelles sont ses
méthodes quelles sont les pratiques
locales et je vois bien qu'il ne les a
jamais contestés même quand c'était
extrêmement violent au conseil municipal
ou d'ailleurs il était le premier à
remettre de l'huile sur le feu avec des
propos que je ne répéterai pas sur ce
plateau
car ils sont au fond sans edifammatoires
mais c'est arrivé énormément de fois
donc je voilà je vois bien le jeu qui se
joue le RN veut faire ça stratégie des
diabolisation ils disent pas en se
désabolise à chaque fois ils disent une
stratégie de dédiabolisation donc c'est
quand même assez clair sur l'objectif
final mais sur le côté un peu factice du
truc vous allez voir qu'il en sera le
parfait emblème on va parler de vos amis
puisque vous dites
pas vos amis alors premier au deuxième
degré la France insoumise
je suis leur ami je le sais au fond
d'eux qui nous aime
on va voir parce
qu'il dit je fais partie de la nuque
donc vous hein entre autres d'avoir fait
perdre 10 sièges à la gauche en refusant
les listes d'union sénatoriale est-ce
que vous leur répondez sincèrement faut
arrêter de faire de la politique de la
jeremiade sur Twitter ou tous les soirs
on se plaint et lui il a dit ça et lui
il a fait ça et moi je vois à mes
collègues chef de partie
se répondent sur les réseaux sociaux à
longueur de soirée moi je moi je fais
l'écologie je travaille avec eux sur ce
qu'ils veulent mais je rentrerai pas
dans ces trucs là j'ai pas le temps j'ai
pas envie ça ne m'intéresse pas et ça
l'intéresse pas les français donc si
vous voulez que je vous explique le
détail de cette crédibilité
aurait dû avoir un sénateur ils en ont
eu un qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça
enfin ça n'aurait pas changé la face du
monde ça n'aurait pas été humiliant pour
eux et je pense que ça ne sert à rien et
je le dis à tout le monde d'humilier ses
partenaires c'est un truc que je vois
trop souvent et on a l'impression que
c'est la nouvelle manière de manager la
politique dans ce pays c'est pas les
méthodes des écologistes nous avons été
les seuls dans ces discussions
sénatoriales à demander que la France
insoumise et un candidat éligible et je
peux même vous le dire c'était dans le
Puy ça mettait pas tout le monde
d'accord localement mais on l'aurait
fait et on le souhaitait il se trouve
que le Parti socialiste et le Parti
communiste ont conclu en accord sans les
écologistes mode duopole les anciens
partis très ancrés ils ont le droit de
faire ça ils ont plus d'assistes que
nous bon ben voilà ils l'ont fait et
puis après quand on est revenu à la
table des discussions c'est des
questions qui étaient déjà pliées donc
on avait plus de prise je trouve ça
dommage c'est fait je vais pas passer
Noël et Nouvel An à revenir sur le sujet
très sincèrement voilà c'est dommage
vous avez mon avis sur la question mais
on peut pas se donner en spectacle comme
ça toutes les semaines et parce qu'en
plus ça nous amène à commenter les trucs
des uns et des autres tout le temps et
franchement c'est usant quoi je préfère
parler de Macron et de la planification
on peut parler des prochaines élections
les européennes toujours pas de liste
d'union de la gauche en perspective les
pression des insoumis n'ont aucune
chance de vous faire changer d'avis
cuvd quand je parle des européennes j'ai
envie de vous parler d'Europe pas de qui
a dit quoi à qui sur quoi sauf que on
continue à demander une liste
je fais ce que je veux et donc vous leur
dit de préparer votre liste quoi je leur
dis rien je leur dis que bon courage et
que je travaille avec eux sur tout ce
qu'ils veulent mais que il se trouve que
nous sommes dans un parti démocratique
que les militants de manière très très
large 86% après 6 mois de pression et de
forcing 86% des militants disent c'est
la bonne stratégie faisons là et donc
Marie Toussaint sera notre tête de liste
elle a toute ma confiance parce que elle
est vraiment super facile qui a mis sur
la table le projet des enfin le sujet
des écossiles elle combat le vivant
depuis un mandat
au Parlement européen elle a elle fait
partie des gens qui ont organisé des
marches climat et donc on va se battre
pour une Europe forte fédérale
écologique sociale c'est notre projet et
on est là pour en convaincre les
dernières questions sur votre partie cet
effet
vos militants on va prouver le
changement de nom du parti en juillet il
faudra vous appeler les écologistes à
partir du mois d'octobre c'est bien ça
on lance un nouveau mouvement c'est pas
on prend Europe écologique
on lance un nouveau mouvement ça fait
150 jours j'étais venu en parler sur
votre plateau qu'on fait les états
généraux de l'écologie on a écouté
massivement toutes celles et ceux qui
avaient un truc à nous dire il y a eu
plus de 30 000 personnes dont 75% ne
sont pas membres de notre parti
politique ni d'aucun autre qui sont
venus nous expliquer ça m'intéresse moi
je viens que cette condition etc donc on
va appuyer sur le bouton reset créer un
nouveau mouvement qui c'est quoi les
anthologie ben vous allez voir on est en
train en ce moment dans les conférences
citoyennes parce qu'on a tiré des gens
au sort pour y travailler avec nous de
faire le parti le plus inclusif possible
ou chacun puisse trouver sa place quel
que soit ce qu'il cherche parce que on
ne s'engage plus en 2023 comme on
s'engageait il y a 40 ans et donc il y a
des gens qui nous disent moi je viens
c'est vraiment pour les formations où je
trouve ça moi je vais faire les
municipales dans ma ville je suis
citoyen vous avez des mairies et des
mois on va faire en sorte que chacun
trouve ce qu'il est venu chercher que ça
se passe bien que ce soit émancipateur
et très sincèrement sur l'écologie on
l'a vu aujourd'hui on a du travail on a
besoin d'être plus pour le mener
la semaine prochaine dès le premier
octobre quand est-ce que vous faites
cette bascule alors la convention de
refondation de nouveaux lancements du
mouvement et le 14 octobre à Pantin la
cité fertile et donc si ça vous
intéresse d'aller sur les écologistes.fr
c'est ouvert à tout le monde vous pouvez
rejoindre ce nouveau mouvement vous
pouvez venir revenir à la Cité fertile
assistée à cette grande fête de
l'écologie ça va pas être en droit
interne ou on vote on s'est engagé à
changer on va changer si vous voulez
participer à cette transformation
marine Tondelier ou vous gardez la tête
vous voulez que je me dis ça j'ai été
élue j'ai fait campagne et j'ai été élu
sur ce projet en décembre il y a même
pas un an donc on a été posé on a été
mandaté pour le mener on le mène et puis
après si les gens veulent que je parte
je partirai s'il veut que je reste le
restaurant mais en tout cas il va y
avoir beaucoup de changements dans les
semaines qui viennent merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir été notre invité
Stéphane la ligne de Ouest-France
l'école française face au fléau du
harcèlement c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup